good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy wedness day
wedness day it's hump day a great day
here at the toast ordinarily but also
made even greater by the fact that jacn
fle has made her great return the cite
is feeling fle I like that rhyme you do
I like the rhyme and I like the beat I
don't love the nickname no come on it's
just like another person you know it's
not me but that's like who cares get
honestly get over it like sorry I just I
want better for me I deserve better I'm
not good with the words like with
nicknames and jacleen fle like came
about naturally like you're just going
to have to embrace
it okay I'm trying I'm trying and I'm
waiting for it to Like Remix itself you
know like fle ble right ble tties wor
bolet T SW B that's the what like the
iteration of my restaurant name I will
be opening a warm bowl facility one day
and right now it was chy warm bowls but
now it's chy WM ballet so beautiful well
I'm so excited to be in studio with you
I'm in New York for the rest of the week
so it's Jackson CLA original recipe and
one thing that's really exciting about
being in studio together is that we can
sing together I know because when we do
remote recording I usually you know I
take the backup vocals because I don't
want it to be cuz it's for the best and
I don't want it to be conflicting it's
hard to sync up but when we're together
we can sing all day all bets are off all
bets are off bet it all on blonde when
all bets are off and Bet On It Bet On It
Bet On It Bet On It bet on it so Jax got
to town yesterday and we had a little
birthday celebration one day late for
your birthday and the long awaited gift
was received and color me shocked to
find you wearing it today cuz I was like
100% convinced you didn't like it and
that you were going to be returning it
no Claudia got me three Leal gifts and
one of them I love so much cuz I'm in my
bow era apparently and I want to show
I'll show the YouTube YouTube exclusive
I'm going to turn around and show you
the bow in my hair I got her three hair
accessories from prder cuz I felt like
one wasn't enough of a gift you know but
even though the one that you're wearing
is like the one that I chose first right
no I totally understand how everything
happened the way that it did and I love
the bow the other ones I might go into
the store and see what my money could
buy me okay no but you got me a gift and
a shopping trip like that's a wonderful
gift that's the thing about gifts in
your adulthood at this point like it's
not appropriate to show up everywhere
with a gift card but that's really what
a gift is oh and yeah and family really
took credit right at a store go balls to
the wall yeah so but you look great
thank you if I have time this week I'm
going to see what they have if not then
I'm going to keep my Tings and I love
them okay opening gifts is like awkward
like cuz you can really like something
and you just like it's hard to it's hard
to communicate that yeah CU everybody's
looking at you like I feel like I was
genuine and happy and it felt like like
I wouldn't like I walked out was like
Ben was like did she like the I'm like
she's going to go to the store like but
now you feel that's why I was shocked
Color Me shocked you feel reassured I
feel reassured I love that you're
wearing it I was so excited cuz like my
outfit it's so New York so all black all
black black turnock black flats and then
just like my fancy bow I honestly look
incredible today look you look because
like my jacket completes the outfit and
I'm not wearing my jacket on the show CU
it's 5,000 degrees in here by the way
that's what I was saying about Kai it's
like it's so great when you have a
fabulous jacket but really it's not that
great when it makes your whole outfit
yeah it didn't make my whole it's like
but it's a big it's AE or part of the
outfit a Cornerstone I'll I'll take a
picture I'll show you guys I'll post it
on my Instagram speaking of Instagram I
did something really fun on my Instagram
stories this morning you did and I felt
like it needed to be done you did and it
did so what's so great about this show
is that it's really like a family thing
if you're a part of the toaster
Community like you know all the jokes
and the references and while I think
that's one of our greatest qualities I
think it does make it difficult to join
to join and jump in because you're like
where do I begin now I don't recommend
going back and listening to to the first
episode ever because it's a thousand
episodes uh the beginning ones probably
weren't that great and can it's a
topical show sometimes my YouTube the
first video that they're serving me on
my homepage is an old episode of the
toast like pink backdrop sometimes I
click on it and the way we are so funny
and we're talking about nonsense like
literally we were talking about the your
tour uh dropping tickets times and we
were just being so funny and and so cute
and effervescent and like every time I
go and watch an old episode I have that
experience old episode of the toast what
what changed no no we're still
hysterical but I feel like we look back
on those episodes and we just assume we
weren't funny no we're like just so cute
and just happy lovely girls oh my God I
love that for us happy lovely girls with
a streak of comedic flare I can't really
go back and watch those happy lovely
girls with a streak of comedic flare
because I have a mole on my
face okay but Su you lost it in 2019 rip
the mole departed I want to say in 2019
a good year
cuz the mole was removed so some of the
episodes I watch from 2019 are post mole
rightstone post Malone we're living a
post malonian era thank God for that
thank God for that so that's good to
hear it is and I think that you should
be kinder to your former self okay and
if you do want to go back and listen to
all 1,000 episodes if you have the time
and the bandwidth and the Curiosity it's
good stuff yeah but it is a topical show
so to go hear about like pop St fromo
people like it even when we're on break
like even people who have listened to
those episodes from 2019 like go back to
those episodes so all like to say is
that we're sympathetic to the fact that
like we're such a tight-knit community
that it does make it difficult to jump
in at any point it feels like clicky and
exclusive and like oh I don't get it I'm
new here so on my Instagram stories I
did um like kind of like an intro guide
refer a refresher of what of our you
know some of our inside jokes are about
our acronyms that we make up you know
Pam naggie [__] wife I've been seeing a
lot of questions about Pam we say he's a
Pam she's a Pou Pam is precious gem of
man so if we say someone's a Pam it's
just like compliment that's a good man
yeah a lot of people thought it was Pam
with a J and they thought you know
precious Jewish extraordinary
man great too kind of love that one even
more me as well the thing about these
acronyms is like make them your own you
know it's not it's not rigid here
everything's flexible you see tury warm
bolet right we're constantly nothing is
static everything you had a restaurant
you wouldn't be able to get proper
signage because the name would always be
changing it would have to be a dry erase
board for my sign or a digital sign
right oh go
not the dry Ras board a digital sign so
we can constantly be updating our
Marquee yeah great idea so if you want
to if you're like new here and you don't
know some of the stuff I most likely
answered your most FAQs pressing
questions on my Instagram and I'll leave
that up I made it a highlight so like if
anybody wants to go they can always just
know you should do more today yeah no I
will but I had to do this so I had to
take a break from my Instagram cool cool
cool cool cool cool we're both like
playing Fun Instagram games on our
Instagram yeah I love this recent game
you've been playing on your Instagram
after we drop every episode share asking
people what their favorite parts of the
episode were yeah I haven't done I've
only done it twice like not every
episode even though I should do it every
episode cuz there's so much and I and
they remind me there's so many like
small nuggets that when I say it it
didn't mean anything to me but then when
someone writes it and quotes I'm like
that's hysterical by the way so me and
Abe have been saying like one of my
favorite added to the list of things I'm
always talking about is Joan Rivers
documentary that's um the list of
celebrity documentaries and um this
isn't her documentary it's her I think
one of her last specials her whole show
is like before I get to the show before
I get to the show I just want to address
each individual group and she goes to
like the gay community women and what
she says about lesbians is like one of
my favorite things she's like the gay
community you can 100% say she told old
people they can't stay for her show
they're boring and they smell and then
she's like gay community 100% can stay
but lesbians have to go in the back and
they're like why Jon and she says
because lesbians don't laugh if they
think something something's funny they
just stand there and go that's funny and
so now when anybody says anything funny
I'm always like that's funny that's
funny that's funny that's like what I do
also I laugh a lot but as you guys know
my laugh is silent yeah I'm not a good
comedic you're podcaster because there's
so much not a good podcaster there's so
much silence that's why we vodcast
Claudia that's why we vodcast I hate the
word vodcast I didn't know what the most
insulting thing someone could say to me
was but telling me I'm not a good
podcaster like hurts okay cuz that's Inc
correct it's not that you're not a good
podcaster like you're not a good
candidate for
podcasting my laugh isn't like the best
laugh for a podcast no and let me but
like my other skills in general you're
an amazing podcaster thank you but
you're also like terrible in inevitable
no no stop saying that okay yeah you
know what I mean right like yeah my
laugh is not the laugh for a podcast if
you had a podcast and you were laughing
on it you're not the worst person for a
podcast you're the worst laugher for a
podcast is that better yeah but at Le
well first of all you could hear that
one right that was really beautiful but
at least I laugh so what about people
who have no sense of humor oh my God I
thought you were like targeting me like
you don't laugh no you laugh yeah you're
like no I really what I always say is
that's funny but at least I'm full of
humor you're good humor you're a good
humor gal Good Humor gal
ghg so we've got a great show is that
correct yeah I mean the show is laid out
before us and we don't know in which
direction it shall go two shows lie
before
me we're going to take the show less
Trav Less Traveled two shows diverged in
a yellow wood and we took the show Less
Traveled we shall actually we don't know
I guess we'll have to come back and
watch it we always over to the show more
traveled right we
could so that's Robert Frost for you cuz
one thing about the toast that's
actually not a joke is we're constantly
talking about poetry
literally every day cuz poetry is more
personal than comedy more personal than
food and I am a poet and I look like a
poet today you do it's giving it's
giving edar Allen Poe I was by the way
literally I was goingon to say that and
it's gonna say it's giving Edgar Allen
Poe it it's giving the Raven oh is that
alen PA yeah it's giving the Ravenclaw
that's me no you're giving the Ravenclaw
and I am That's So
Raven we can end the show now yeah cuz
we took the show has
traveled the show has traveled would be
Us ending the show cuz we always do a
show that would also be like the show
without lights because we need to do the
ads oh okay you need to expel yourself I
need to expel myself okay so without
further ad did did do here are the fast
five stories that you need to know and
the fast five stories that you need to
know oh wa I'll tell you in a second are
brought to you by l'oral this episode of
the toast is brought to you by the new
L'Oreal Paris bright reveal dark spot
serum and the broadspectrum SPF F50
daily lotion you've got dark spots no
you don't game over so when it comes to
dark spots I feel like after the summer
we all are just walking around with dark
spots on our face and the first time you
get them it's like really jarring you're
like what is this so you need to be
protecting your skin and that's what the
spf50 daily lotion from L'Oreal is
fabulous for but then when you still get
dark spots the L'Oreal Paris bright
revealed dark spot Serum is a fabulous
option to get rid of some of those dark
spots cuz I hate the way they make me
look my f they they the way they make my
face look so like blotchy and like my
tone is is not even but there's really
great results from this L'Oreal product
so it visibly Fades all dark spots up to
40% you after 12 weeks there's up to 40%
less visible less visibility on post
acne marks 43% less V visibility on dark
spots and 49% more even tone so in one
week it starts fading even the most
stubborn dark spots and after two weeks
your skin looks clearer your skin
texture looks re refined and smooth and
it's made for all skin tones and it's
even suitable for sensitive skin then
when it comes to protecting your skin
from those dark spots check out the
bright reveal spf50 daily lotion it
visibly reduces the appearance of dark
spots and resists sun induced signs of
aging so 100% of dark spots are
intensified by the Sun and 96% of women
agree that this L'Oreal SPF 50 daily UV
lotion doesn't leave a white cast so you
can wear it under your makeup or you can
just wear it bare and not have like a
thick layer of like cream on your face
um discover the new bright revealed dark
spot Duo visit Target online and in
store to buy yours today today's episode
is also brought to you by Thrive
Cosmetics whether you like fresh faced
full glass or somewhere in between
you've probably seen th of Cosmetics
viral tubing mascara you know the one in
the turquoise tube that tury wears every
day that's all over her very very viral
Tik Tok get ready with me is well Thrive
Cosmetics beauty products are certified
100% vegan and cruelty-free they're made
with Clean Skin loving ingredients high
performance in trademarked formulas and
uncompromising standards so there's a
lot of viral products from Thrive
Cosmetics I happen to love that tubing
mascara I have very straight lashes that
can hold a curl and this is pretty much
the uh mascara I wear every single day
but they also have their semi-permanent
smoothing lipsticks that every everybody
loves you can get visibly Fuller
smoother and nourished lips with a
creamy satin finish it's fade free for
up to 8 hours and it won't bleed dry or
settle into your fine lines also the
brilliant eye brightener it's a
highlighter stick that's made to
brighten and open your eyes giving you
an instant eye lift one of my favorite
things uh to do in makeup is put like a
little highlighter in the corner of my
eye and sometimes that's hard with like
a brush but this stick from Thrive
Cosmetics is like really particular very
sharp like you can really get in there
under your brow bone looks fabulous and
then of course the liquid lash
extensions mascara it'll last all day
without clumping smudging or flaking and
it looks like lash extensions but
without the damaging glue or the salon
prices so Thrive Cosmetics is a luxury
Beauty brand that also gives back right
now you can get an exclusive 20% off
your first order at Thrive cosmetics.com
toast that's Thrive Cosmetics CA
ms.com toast for 20% off your first
order Thrive
cosmetics.com toast today's episode is
also brought to you by Squarespace
Squarespace is the all-in-one website
platform for entrepreneurs to stand out
and succeed online whether you're just
starting out managing a growing brand
Squarespace makes it easy to create a
beautiful website engage with your
audience and sell anything from products
to content to time all in one place all
on your terms so you need a website like
I don't know what you do but I guarantee
you you need a website photographer you
want to showcase your beautiful
portraits videographer you want to
showcase your work you want to sell
e-commerce you want to start a you know
like a little side hustle making a
website can be really intimidating but
Squarespace literally does it all for
you it's so easy I've made a lot of
websites in my day don't forget I was a
blogger you know back in the day and I
can tell you Squarespace is the best
their templates look so professional
people will think that you spent
thousands of dollars on like a big fancy
company but it was just Squarespace
maybe it's Squarespace so whether you
want to upload an asset Library like for
a photographer or videographer you want
to sell custom merch create an online
store their flexible web website
templates are really easy to get started
with they have designs for every
category and use case and then you can
customize your look update the content
and add features to fit your unique
needs one of the great things about
Squarespace is that if you sell stuff
online but then you also go to like a
trade show and you want to sell in
person they have a point in s point of
sale where you can sell in person by
connecting a Squarespace reader to the
Squarespace app and keep your orders
inventory and customer data in sync with
your online store so head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com toast to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain that's
squarespace.com toast for to save 10%
off of your first purchase of a website
or a domain J thank you ler you're
welcome our first story People's sexiest
man alive 2023 is here and it
is Patrick Dempsey now I have thoughts
but I feel like once a year we have this
conversation because they're the same
thoughts every year yeah we do have this
conversation once a year because it's a
yearly thing right and I always feel the
same way which is no shade to Patrick
Dempsey an extremely handsome man but
like why is the sexiest man alive like
always 60 years old and always somebody
who's been sexy for 30 years okay that
part doesn't bother me what bothers me
is like in the chart of Patrick Dempsey
relevancy like it's not up there right
now like he's been as you know mixed
dreamy for 20 years like gry's Anatomy
is not at its peak like why now why this
SMA yeah I don't know why now why this
SMA it's a good
question but also I think it's important
to know like People magazine like is a
tabloid and I do think like at his
height like he probably wouldn't have
agreed like they can't just name you
people sexy as man alive you sit down
for an interview and a photo like it's a
mutual thing it's not like a list that
they put together without your
permission so I think CU a lot of people
are like oh but like the hottest guy
this year is like who who's hot right
now the actual sex maluma like whatever
Travis Kelce he would never sit down
with People magazine so we have to keep
that in mind I actually think he would
but I understand what you're saying
maluma wouldn't no like so maybe they
get people on their decline because it
has to be it's a two-way street a
mutually agreed upon list and I do think
maybe some of the elders are more
interested in that sort of press whereas
the youngs are like oh no I want to go
on the podcast no like I want to be
Esquire I want to be Esquire yeah so I
think like People magazine definitely is
like a publication that skews older
because it's like a old school magazine
they're digital obviously but like this
is this is a list that like older people
know about and like respect so so we're
aging ourselves by talking about it
every year no I don't um I don't respect
the list but I I know it yeah and it's
just one of those cultural things that's
been around for a while that like we
should keep around because it's a cute
idea and I'm sure one day it'll be
ruined you know it's sexist literally um
hetero like normative male Centric
misogynist that's all coming so I'm
going to enjoy it while we have it I
actually don't think it's coming I feel
like they're constantly evolving cuz
they do most beautiful woman alive I
don't know why it's beautiful and sexy
for a man it's beautiful for a woman but
sexy for a man and then they have like
all the other ones like greatest hair
you know yeah like they keep adding
different categories with the times I
mean there was a category this year of
sexia
Swifty what and it was like Travis Kelce
oh Channing Tatum oh not like fans Oh I
thought they were like celebrities I'm
right here tur sex 50 right here
tury um yeah they do their um they did
sexiest TV star James Mars I'm going to
agree with you on oh I was going to say
he's on TV but I forgot about what was
that show called jury duty yeah jury
duty yeah sexiest Blockbuster star so
like movies Chris Hemsworth I was
literally going to say that uh sexiest
athlete Travis KY Travis Kelce these
ones interview it's just like a you know
they just put it together perative yeah
you don't need to agree to it sexiest
musician Harry Styles yep wow wow
sexiest morning show host
Jackie no let me think like this is just
men yeah like Willie gist wait let me
think let me think actually you could
get it who's our favorite morning show
host that we talk about the most not
Kelly she's sh better inoa no no wait
let me think who the [__] do we talk
about in the mornings okay you probably
don't think of her as a morning
her co-host yeah I know I know what the
hell is his name mark canos yeah
sexi they're like not really morning by
the way there shows on like they're top
of the morning it's not noon no it's
like 6 a.m. right oh sorry I take it
back yeah uh sexiest
Grandpa you're probably not going to get
this yeah I'm not Pierce
broen okay he's sexy and he's a grandpa
Aro okay Aro sexiest Grandpa
okay okay sexiest Pedro Pascal and it's
all the different kinds of Pedro
pascals
okay sexiest funny guy oh let me
think you're making like a disgusting
face do you hate this
person I just like it wouldn't be my
choice John malany no but he was
nominated okay wait let me think sexy is
funny guy and by the way these are
reader choices so there's like Nomes oh
so who do people like love I don't know
who Trevor Noah oh I mean I've seen that
ass in person Don't make me say that
story again no he's got a big ass and he
ain't afraid to wear a tight pair of
khakis sexiest Ken from Barbie Ryan gos
yeah he did win sexiest new
dad Zack weinreb Tom Heston who knew he
was a new dad okay I get the Tom's
confused Taylor Swift with the yeah yeah
no but this I got for a second I thought
it was Tom Holland no I'm like he's 14
no no no Tom with a t-shirt Tom with a
T-shirt has a baby how lovely he's a
nice boy sexiest Tik Tock star tury Lou
free Bush male oh B offer celebrity
jayen
Noble he dates
stas I think let me see a picture these
all these boys I don't know that oh no
I'm sorry no that's Jaden this is um
Jaylen Noble Jaylen Noble yeah no I've
seen him on the talk what does he get up
to up there he um dates Monae McMichael
who's like a big beauty girl I know
Monae yeah and then who are the other
three Josh Richard I don't know the
other
two their name should be caption he is
1.2 million people subscrib to see his
post about his dogs mon McMichael that's
why like people really know him got it
uh sexiest podcast host wait and
actually do you agree um he's a sexy
podcast host and he's a close friend of
L turd and it's not your husband and
it's not Josh peek oh but like your next
best friend that does podcasting wait
who Taylor lner that's a good one yeah
that's a good one he was up against Dak
sheeper Nick vile and Dom
Gabriel I hope they do this for women I
hope so too people call me um that's an
interesting group of male podcasters and
not the top of mind no like where are
the smartest guys where's Joe Rogan I
would have assumed D Shepard yeah that's
fair what other podcasts are there Tom
seura Tim Dylan so when you were saying
that I thought you were going to say Tim
Dylan I was like he is my close personal
friend he's your third closest friend
who call me fat yeah oh my God stop
sexiest guy you're streaming due to the
strike wait what sexiest guy you're
streaming due to the strike so is that
like a influencer no it's like an old
show oh oh oh oh oh that's a funny
category it could be like anyone from
Friends M oh big from Sex in the City
okay no Max Sheffield that's who I'm
streaming no oh Luke from Gilmore Girls
no I don't even know who this person is
honestly let me see it's he's from
Supernatural Jensen
Ackles I'm sorry to this man but who
were the other people I maybe that
looked like Gilmore Girls Who were the
other people I see from the office were
um Criminal Minds Shamar Moore gilm
Shamar Moore was robbed by the way I
okay I'm so glad you just brought up sh
finished Gilmore Girls Milo vent tamiga
or the offices John krinski oh okay
those are good ones I was pretty close
with Milo um yeah so I have always known
this but I ended up on a side of Tik Tok
where people were talking about the
Shamar more fandom and I was like these
are my people so I watch Criminal Minds
and it's one of those shows that's like
been on TV for a hundred years the
people on the show are so rich but
they're not like uber Uber famous it's
just kind of like a soap opera at this
point and Shamar Moore is like the
hottest guy on the show and he like has
this like relationship with a girl who
works in Tech he like calls her baby
girl but like they don't like they don't
[__] like that but but they're like
there's like immense love for another
there's a rapport but Shamar Moore like
is this really really incredibly
handsome guy and he has and the people
who watch the show are like these older
women and they love him Jackie so like
okay and he knows it and oh oh oh all my
lipsticks lying hold on is he on Cameo
honestly he's too well paid to be on
Cameo but I wouldn't be surprised if he
was but he like knows about these
girlies that like love him and he so
like plays into that like on his
Instagram love that okay Shamar Moore
this is
his oh maybe yeah people were just like
okay this is his Instagram bioex let's
flirt goofball Inspire dream succeed and
beat multiple sclerosis and cancer
together like he knows what he's doing
like he's playing and like his Instagram
is just a thirst trap after thirst trap
after thirst trap how many followers
does he have four million like I'm
telling you not enough people talk about
like the underbelly of Pop Culture that
includes the shmar more fandom I'm so
glad you just brought that up like I
feel like he kind of reminds me of
Elliot Stabler like similar show sim
okay but imagine if Elliot Stabler
played into no but like now he does you
know with his shirt off and in the
commercials and I feel like Shar MO is
10x like no but it's like the same sort
of thing where like for some people like
Elliot Stabler is their sexiest man of
Life OT he would have been a good choice
he would have Elliot ster is like a
little bit more popular in culture like
Criminal Minds is not like a a Big Show
in the sense that like everybody knows
it no but I feel like recently like
everyone kind of like came together in
Law and Order like had this like it's
always popular right it's always been
popular but it like came out of the
Shadows a little B yeah because like
every celebrity everybody was like I
love lawn and so like Stabler like had
his moment in the sun I feel like that
will happen with what saying honestly I
love Shamar Moore like I'm obsessed with
this thing and maybe especially because
of the SAG after strike more people are
feeling that way maybe yeah sag Afra
don't forget about it don't um next
story if we're ready to move on sexy
news I was getting a little hot it is
also sexy news most of our news is sexy
well cuz we're sexy and we kind of just
make everything sexy we like make
everything so sexy I just want to say
look I am a lot of
things but I'm not like sexy same like
I'm beautiful I'm really I know I'm like
a Timeless Beauty I know that I'm
hysterical I'm very smart people don't
realize that I am not sexy no literally
same and I've never really tried to be
sexy and in the very few moments that I
have like it's giving loser you know
there's a thin line between sexy and
Loser yeah yeah 100% yeah you can't be
everything to everyone but sometimes
like you're so sexy like you can't even
cross that line and actually I think
that's never been more ever evident than
with shmar Moore like cuz he you could
definitely look at some of his stuff and
be like this is cringe and he's like
playing to the old ladies but he's so
handsome and and naturally sexy that it
doesn't matter you know yeah not only my
not sexy I can't even use the word un
ironically just no you literally just
convulsed while saying it I know like I
would never look at someone or describe
a person or a thing M using the sord in
a serious way in a Ser I only use the
that word once a year when we talk about
sexy as man alive I happen to agree but
when it comes you know right before man
and alive I feel very comfortable yeah
like the word sexy if the word sexy was
personified into a TV show it would be
the idol on HBO exactly yuck
exactly well our next story sexy content
news Mean Girls movie trailer has just
dropped I wouldn't say it's sexy you
wouldn't no why couldn't it be no would
you say original Mean Girls is sexy no
oh it's not not no it's not okay sure I
guess I don't know what sexy means
either exhibit
a um The Mean Girls trailer has dropped
the movie comes out in January and so
this is a movie based on the musical the
Broadway musical that was based on the
original movie yes because when I was
watching the trailer I was like oh
there's a character Regina Georgia oh
they're just remaking the original I'm
like oh that's the [__] point because
it's based on the musical which is based
on the movie and the musical was very
popular I never saw it and that like is
something I regret um we watched the
trailer together it looks excellent yeah
so it's the original movie same plot
same characters and there's just like a
little more current references thrown in
so like there's Tik Tok
stuff mostly Tik Tok stuff yeah yeah
it's like a modern take on Mean Girls
It's Mean Girls for the new generation
yeah even though like the original movie
wasn't old enough for it to be for the
old generation like I think this new
generation could still watch it and
appreciate it like yeah but I guess it
doesn't have like technology and that's
like so important in high school yeah
they're all on their flip phones yeah
but like literally Tina is still the
teacher and she looks exactly the same
so the casting was really interesting
cuz a lot of people stay the same Tina
Fay the principal yeah I can't keep you
here P four but then there were some new
um casting so Regina George is played by
Renee rap who played Regina George on
the Broadway stage people loved her I
love her I'm glad she's acting because I
feel like she just quit Secret Lives of
college girls right sex lives of college
girls excuse me and she's like doing
music her music career is blowing up of
college sexy lives of college girls I
thought she was like done with acting
but I love that she did this um John Ham
plays coach Carr yeah obsessed bsy
Phillips plays Regina's mom who was Amy
polar I don't love mm- uh Pam from The
Office plays Katie's mom oh that's a
good one by the way she kind of looks
like Katie's mom originally yeah well I
wanted to see who played Katie because
she she looked like a fresh face to me
she looked familiar from something for
me okay look it up Katie Haren and
you're right Tina Fay looks exactly the
same exactly the same oh and the guy I
don't know who the guy who plays like
Daman 2.0 but he looked like every time
I giggled in the trailer it was because
of him oh yeah yeah okay wait I'm only
getting the old ktie Haron so I'm going
to have to read this article give me a
moment take your
time jingle bell jingle bell jingle bell
rock Jingle Bell swing and jingle bell
sting slow and gory rice oh what else is
she in she's in Nice Guys nice guys
spider man homecoming I don't think you
know her I'm telling you she looks so
familiar hold on and the movie itself is
a musical yes I saw a bunch of like
dance sequences yeah I got to learn some
of the songs like that'll be exciting oh
she was in the last thing he told me
which I didn't watch but that's so
that's not how I know her I don't know I
don't think you know her I guess I don't
know her she kind of looks to me like um
Timothy sham sister oh that would have
been great Kimber that would great that
would have been great and with Renee
yeah um this actually looks very good
I'm not like a huge fan of like
revamping you know things but not enough
people talk about how mean girls like
changed it mean girls literally raised
me I'm pretty sure on this show we have
one one Mean Girls reference every
single day and it's like not even so
overt it's just part of our everyday
jargon we were raised on that we loved
that movie and when I watch it sometimes
it'll be on and I'll just like watch it
and when I focus on it I'm like I know
every line of this movie never watch me
girls every single line is something
that I say in every everyday life you
can go shave your back now bye Jason
it's so crazy some on my um story where
I was like what's has you cackling and
someone replied the fact that you guys
quote me girls backwards and forwards
and like we I don't even think we know
like consciously when we're doing it and
it's like when you ask me my favorite
movie I wouldn't say Mean Girls cuz
that's like such a basic Choy answer but
like it's my favorite movie I if you ask
me like Mean Girls would be in my top
three favorite movies it's so good it's
so good and it gets better with age
Anda whoer respons the enie is respons
for this like I have hope I think it be
I will be it I have hope too so far
every like Mean Girls affiliate except
for like Mean Girls 2 and stuff like
that has um done well kept the Integrity
of the original film intact so I'm
hopeful I'm hopeful too I just um oh
Mean Girls remember that one no it was
like twins mean girls but those weren't
like affiliated with Tina Fe they were
not even mean girls too was not yeah
so good yeah so that's
exciting see you in January that's not
even far no that's fabulous it was a
pretty quick turnar around like where's
Legally Blonde four where's Legally
Blonde four we've been talking about
that since the Inception of this show
yeah they said Mindy Kaling was writing
the script like we got so excited we all
the small updates we got were all
positive and now they'll blame sag Astra
but I just want you guys to know like
you actually can't blame sag Astra for
this you can blame them for a lot of
stuff but not mean girls for because
it's been four years Legally Blond four
Legally Blond four yeah by the way I
forgot to mention Theo's in studio with
us today la la la la la la la
la the season to be CR la la la la la la
la Hey fa how you feeling tell us give
us a fa update he I told you guys has
arthritis he has a doctor's appointment
with like the leading hip guy but they
had like a three- we waiting list so
it's in two weeks so he's just suffering
for 2 weeks he's on pain meds nice yeah
but they're not like sleepy ones he
you'd never know it should I pick him up
and bring him to my chair he's so happy
I'm going to do it anyway oh okay good
sure you scared him oh my God my heart
my
heart oh I know he's in pain oh my angel
Bo in pain are you okay my love I'm so
sorry oh my God he needs this
mommy I'm depressed I wish I didn't
touch I'm depressed I tried to tell you
but okay but he needs his mommy he does
need his mommy these boys need their
mommy I also do think he's going deaf
like so when I call him he doesn't hear
him that's why I he got scared when I
rubbed his back falling apart this far
he's falling apart but he's got he's far
strong far
strong are you ready for our next story
yes it's number three don't worry oh
okay I have the biggest wedgie like okay
I don't know how to realistically pick
my wedgie while Theo's on my lap I think
you just got to go for it okay take the
plunge got it great Switching gears
Israeli actress gal gdau plans a
Hollywood screening of the brutal Hamas
terror attack atrocities so Israeli
actress gadoo was reportedly
spearheading a Hollywood screening of a
47-minute video of the atrocities
committed by the terrorist group Kamas
during the October 7th surprise attack
on Israel the footage provided by the
Israeli Defense Forces the IDF will will
be shown to a select group of
celebrities and influential figures I24
news reported the first screening is
planned to host 120 viewers with
potential additional screenings based on
interest so if you're unfamiliar the IDF
put together about a 45 minute video of
what happened on October 7th and it's
footage from the terrorist body cams
themselves they filmed everything they
wore body cams they filmed everything
and they collected these body cams off
of the terrorists after the attack and
then put together 45 minutes worth of
footage so that the world because
everybody's saying it didn't happen
people are saying it didn't happen they
showed it to the world media I think it
is available um what's the website is it
like there's a website like if you it's
really really graphic they're hosting
screenings like actually in the city I
don't think I can go no I it's not for
everyone there's a lot of different like
feelings people have about like if
people should watch it if if it should
be seen I don't think absolutely
everyone needs to watch it especially if
you understand what happened and you
don't need convincing um but I guess
gadoo feels that in Hollywood in her
circles people could benefit from
knowing what happened because I I know
you and I know and the people that we
talk to know but it's clear that a lot
of people don't really know people they
think it's like Jewish propaganda like
there are no hostages this is all a lie
like they think it's literally
propaganda if they knew and they saw
this they wouldn't be saying the things
that they're saying and they continued
to say those things well then they
should be arrested yeah 100% I'm beyond
curious like who of gagod do's invitees
like will be going I think is really
like that's using your platform and your
privilege for like immense good and it's
like you can people can talk and you can
listen to influential voices whatever
but like there's something to be said
about just like seeing and the facts and
and making your mind up for yourself but
if you don't if you don't have the
information then it's hard to make an
informed opinion but like here this is
what happened yeah make an opinion for
yourself yeah so I think more people
need to watch it because it's clear that
people don't know what happened like I
think on college campuses like if if you
want to go to a terrorist rally you
should have to watch this first I agree
required read We Can't Stop people from
protesting and freedom of speech but
like you should know what you're
standing for yeah and people are
planning to Rally outside this event
there's already an organized event to
like rally outside she's holding it at
the Holocaust Museum and there's like an
organized event already like show up and
protest this propaganda but I actually
don't understand why Hamas supporters
would be against people watching it
because it's like Hamas filmed it so
that watch it like your boys want people
to see it no there's I don't think it's
you know worth our time to find logic in
all of this no but I'm just saying your
boys wanted people to see it your boys
those are your boys yep if you're
protesting this if you're tearing down
posters those are your boys hi my love
oh F I know I feel like he's hating it
up here should I put him back down he
seems fine but like he's not
resting well now he's on camera he's
working camera he's working work it he's
a working boy Bruno's retired he told me
I said Bruno like I mean he moved to
Florida it's early retirement I said
it's giving Tom Brady he's coming back
100% Bruno's such like the boy who cried
retirement 100%
yeah are you ready for our next story I
don't know am I no you're not okay I
don't know that you ever will be
honestly oh oh okay okay no you guys I'm
not ready do you want to know why yes
because the next story is brought to you
by Wella Wella professionals has over
140 years of experiencing of experience
developing products initially used for
professional use and previously only
sold in salons and consistently is
ranked among the top loved Brands by
professional stylists but now they're
making products for you I have so many
of their products I have to say I've
never gotten more compliments on my hair
especially because I've been working out
so much and washing my hair less like
I'm really worried about my hair
smelling and I use a lot of products
from they are the best smelling products
ever and their ult their new line the
ultimate repair is the most premium line
line to date it was developed with over
140 years of experience in research to
deliver the very best the miracle hair
rescue that's a product that I love that
I use it on my wet hair it smells so
good and it repairs your hair in only 90
seconds with key ingredients Aha and
Omega 9 to rebuild the hair bonds inside
the strands and replenish the outside
barrier of damaged hair their bonding
serum repairs hair damage in 90 SEC
seconds this luxury product has Rich
textures and floral scents and it is
designed for all hair types and textures
it's a perfect luxury leave-in spray
treatment that everyone can benefit from
so here's how to use it after you get
out of the shower spray the ultimate
repair Miracle Hair rescue as many times
as needed we recommend 5 to 10 all over
your wet hair wait 90 seconds before
styling and that's it this allow the
allows the product to work its magic all
day no rinsing Jax I know you don't have
a lot of time as a mom of two um and
that's what's so great about the Wella
ultimate repair is that this product
takes 90 seconds and you don't have to
wash it out that's my favorite part I
love that it's easy to apply and you can
leave it in all day it's like what are
you supposed to get out of the shower
put the product in your hair wait and
then go back in shower when you were in
the shower you can try ultimate repair
Miracle Hair rescue with 10% off the
travel size on Amazon by using promo
code toast it's the ultimate repair
Miracle Hair rescue 10% off the travel
size on Amazon with code toast today's
episode is also brought to
you by far by amazing man today's
episode is brought to you by natural
diamonds.com did you know you can tell
the difference between a lab grown
diamond and a natural diamond lab grown
diamonds are mass-produced in factories
in just a few weeks and are easily
detected due to their distinct patterns
on the other hand natural diamonds are
just over a billion years old and
support the livelihood of over 10
million people worldwide the positive
impact of natural diamonds is widespread
around 80% of the value of every rough
diamond remains in local communities and
supports infrastructures Healthcare
education and Environmental Protection
so next time you're thinking of
celebrating a special moment in your
life remember that your natural diamond
also protects vulnerable Wildfire
species and brings prosperity to many
less fortunate communities around the
world for more information visit natural
diamonds.com so natural diamonds is n a
r a diamonds.com lab grown diamonds as
we know can be mass-producing factories
they take just a few weeks and they are
easily detected due to their distinct
pattern so again holiday season is
coming up thinking of investing in a
beautiful piece of jewelry for yourself
or someone in your life next time you're
thinking of celebrating a special moment
in your life choose a natural diamond
for more information visit natural
diamonds.com that's natural diamonds.com
Jack let me give this back to you back
to Jack backs to Jack cuz our next story
is some exciting content news okay in
the spirit of documentaries that are
just being very good recently okay
Netflix has a new documentary coming out
about Sylvester Stallone oh yeah Netflix
is kind of in their celebrity
documentary era yeah I was there a year
ago it's sagra compliant oh it is yeah I
guess CU it's like unscripted so he has
a documentary called Sly coming out and
um it'll be on Netflix he'll be telling
the story of his life including some um
tragic personal moments and I'm thinking
it's going to be good yeah that he I
think he's a good person for a
documentary because his Heyday a lot of
people you know aren't familiar with
even myself like obviously I know him
but I don't really know like what Rocky
is he's an actor or a boxer he acted as
a boxer in Rocky no he's like I mean
Rocky the thing is like we've never seen
seen Rocky I don't know that I've ever
consumed a piece of Sylvester's content
no I haven't but I like he's massive no
I think that's why he's perfect for it
cuz there's so much there and he's
perfect for it for us because it's like
oh I know who this is but I haven't
engaged in the content and now I'll get
like a a summation yeah no I I think
it's he this reminds me a lot of David
Beckham like obviously we know watch
David Beckham play soccer and I don't
really know like his journey through
soccer now I do but I had really I know
he was a soccer player yeah so I think
he's kind of great and I think he has
like a really interesting family life
too he's been married for a really long
time they've struggled in their marriage
but they worked it out like a bunch of
really beautiful kids I think people
will end up being really interested in
him and his family like I see them
having a reality show they have a
reality show I think it came out it's
supposed to be on Paramount plus I get
them confused with the Bradshaw Bunch
cuz they're like always on a no but the
Bradshaw like I don't know Mr Bradshaw I
do aside from Bradshaw Bunch no I mean
like he's all over my TV when I'm
watching football no now I do but I
think I first saw him like in EC
commercials yeah yeah yeah no I had
heard the name but yeah and also not to
make this story about me but I was on
the plane with Sylvester a few months
ago him and his wife yeah I sat in front
of them oh actually yeah I remember that
and they were lovely I love that so you
like to watch lovely people you do like
he wasn't a diva no not at all I didn't
even notice him I wonder if I would have
recognized him if you had seen the
documentary no if if Zach didn't
recognize him oh do you know what I mean
you would have you think yeah even
though I'm not a rocky Licious girl but
don't say that about yourself you are
rocky Licious Jacks and sexy and Rocky
Licious and sexy get you a girl who can
do both so I'm excited to learn more
about Sly in his fourth coming
documentary Sly it's also a good name it
is Sly it's very similar to Beckham yeah
who else should have a documentary like
this for us like people who we know of
but we haven't dug into I mean they
should really do like people the younger
generation needs to know about they need
to do a Joan Rivers documentary like
it's time yeah like she did her own and
it's amazing and I cannot recommend
enough to watch it like if there's one
thing you watch before you die it should
be that but it's like that is enough for
me because I need Jones first person POV
I don't want to documentary about her
people talking about her it's just going
to make me sad yeah but if they did it
about her with like clips of like the
her story as like a female comedian like
her story it needs to be it really does
it needs to be told young kids they're
so sensitive this generation like they
need Joan to whip them into shape her
story is history uh
100% and most importantly it's history
yeah it's his story and her story right
anyone else like vague abstract you know
who I felt that way about before I dug
into him who Elvis well yeah the movie
like piqu my interest in Elvis I started
watching old videos I read Priscilla's
book and I needed to know about Elvis
are you going to see the new Priscilla
movie I might if it comes across my desk
in a way that's enjoyable for me to
watch maybe add it to our family holiday
List Holiday I also added a movie while
Olivia was on the show bidler on the
roof I know I um I heard we're due for a
rewatch okay yes wait I have another
movie add The Sound of Music I've never
seen it it's on the list oh okay that's
how you know the list is good is good
and this is the point of making lists
like you guys make lists I'm telling you
so wait what was it
what did we just
say we needed to make the list
sooner no wait what did we say before
that no wait we're going to back up
Elvis Elvis
Priscilla and Fiddler on the Roof and
yeah yeah yeah and honestly maybe Sly
maybe Sly if we haven't watched it
already maybe Sly you know what else is
a good show that I'm watching that it
would be good for your list but I'm
watching it so it's not good for mine
lessons in chemistry yeah it's a good
familyfriendly show so sweet so far love
and people were saying how could it be
your comfort show because if you've seen
it like it's not that comforting because
I read the book and I know what's coming
nothing surprises me love that for you
and there airG go I can find it
comforting so Sly see you soon on
Netflix love that are you ready for our
fifth and final story I am Sophia
Vergara is already falling for her new
man's orthopedic surgeon Justin Salamon
she's falling for her new man's
orthopedic
surgeon
or her new man is an orthopedic surgeon
grammar is important kids yeah man's is
no man's comma comma she's following for
her new man comma orthopedic surgeon
Justin or whatever his name is yes but I
said man's what's his name Justin
Salomon wait I wait his name is Justin
is that yeah I didn't even hear you say
that I just guessed okay but you've
certainly heard me say it no no okay no
I didn't
like a part of your brain like a
subconscious part of my bra yeah cuz
Justin's not a name you typically reach
for it's always like Fred yeah Sophia
begar is already reportedly falling for
her orthopedic surgeon new boyfriend I
thought you were going to say like you
know him like he operated on your
food no or maybe like he's Theo's hip
surgeon no that's Dr asy Dr asy um
Sophia's falling for Justin the more she
spends time with him they have amazing
chemistry and her friends think they
make a wonderful couple so there's a
photo of them in a car um leaving or
entering into a date she was Paparazzi
and he was Paparazzi and I just like
wonder what that's like foric surgeon I
feel like immense immense because I'm an
empath I feel immense sadness and almost
grief on behalf of Sophia Vergara
because like once you've slept with Joe
magnin and
Elio there's only one way to go and it's
down and that's not a slight towards
Justin literally you could say the same
thing about him and her because like
he's the sexiest man alive and she's the
sexiest woman alive there's only going
down yes but maybe it's just because I
think there are so many beautiful women
in the world like there's there are so
many and there's less sexy there's only
one Joe man Janella like for real he's
cuz you want to know what it is he's so
different looking than like any man in
Hollywood he's literally a werewolf like
he's just this big and Sophia regar is
so so so so so so
beautiful but there are a lot of
beautiful women and there's only one Joe
manin okay well I appreciate for her
that she's not trying to replace Joe
like she kind of went in a different
direction like I'm going to date someone
for their mind for their hands he's also
a good-look surgeon yeah of course I
mean it doesn't hurt you know yeah but
he's like smart he's she's not like just
trying to copy and paste Joe right which
I love and he was spotted with a a
regular as well a regular dular yeah I
remember a Normy yeah wow it's so
interesting maybe they're both so
scarred from their relationship and from
being in like a high power couple like
star power just give me a regular
degular please yeah no like they went so
in the opposite direction things must
have really went South yeah no but it's
good no it's good give the normies a
chance I love it's literally how one of
my books starts you know like just a
regular girl with a movie star obsessed
you should write a fan fiction about Joe
manginello and his lady love I actually
feel like all the smut books I read are
about Joe manelo like when I'm picturing
the guy it's Joe manello yeah and then
also this would be a good storyline his
ex-wife sexy woman Al liive yeah like
I'm sorry if you've read things we never
got over Knox is Joe manell I didn't It
Happened One Summer Brendan is Joe
manello speaking of books you know what
came out yesterday iron flame sequel to
Fourth Wing okay so update on Fourth
Wing I sat down again yesterday like I
can't read it what are you up to um like
I don't even know I don't I can't even
understand the world so you're reading
it too slowly it's not going to happen
for you yeah she just got the option to
like go back to scribe Hood you're
nowhere no I know I can't Jackie it
sucks you're nowhere like I hate it you
can't say I didn't enjoy it where you
are cuz nothing happened and I'm still
worldl building yeah I hate
it we'll clip this in four years when
she watches the first movie I wish I
read the book oh yeah they're making a
movie like I want to be a part of it you
Claudia it's not too late you would you
would actually still be ahead early I
know if you get in now on the ground
floor I know before the sequel pops off
and before the movie comes out I know
it's never too late and it's never too
late to become a redhead you guys our
final episode of the year is coming out
the first week of December and we are
reading the woman Nam Me by Britney
Spears so if you're a pop culture girly
and wanting an aspiring
redhead is the time never too late uh
those were the past five stories oh wow
that was quick yeah I guess that that
one just like snuck up on us was that
yeah that was five um I'm going to put
Theo down cuz we're going to do dear
toasters okay and he doesn't I will do
you want me to do de toasters no you
want to read it no no that way he's
snoring I going to disturb him again my
arm hurts oh my gosh okay where can I
find these here the pages the pages app
first up but also um we usually choose
like four or five yeah so which ones so
the one that I just need you to read is
like a really short one okay I think I
saw it it said dear um hi
I'm oh you just said his name this is
supposed to be
anonymous we'll bleep it we'll bleep it
we'll bleep it okay he put that in okay
Jackie as he continues to say he's eight
years old not you blaming an eight-year
old hi I'm bleep I'm eight years old and
I listen to your podcast with my mom
sometimes if someone is mean to your
friend and you want to stand up for them
but you feel overwhelmed what do you do
it's a really good question because how
do we balance being a good friend to
others while also like protecting our
pece and you don't want to feel
overwhelmed and I guess you just have to
weigh the two options like what's what's
more important to you you know being a
good friend and defending your friend
who might not be able to defend himself
or maybe you potentially being
uncomfortable yeah and I think for me
the way I think about it is like okay I
will stand up for this person and and
I'll be uncomfortable for that but like
that will make me feel good versus not
being uncomfortable in that moment not
standing up for them but then like when
I go to sleep at night like not feeling
good about myself because I didn't stand
up for the things I believe in and like
what you thought was right so the
question is like is your discomfort
worth doing the right thing and I think
it is and I think that ultimately when
you do the right thing even if it's
uncomfortable you feel really good about
yourself versus if you don't do anything
you don't experience that discomfort it
will weigh on you the fact that oh I'm
not a person who does the right thing
right like will you regret standing up
for him no you will not but will you
regret not standing up for him or her
yes yes you will yes you will especially
if you're writing in and you're a good
you're a good boy good hearted boy yeah
yeah do do the right thing agreed even
if there are going to be times where
you're going to wish that you didn't
there going to be times like you're
going to do it and you're going to say
shoot I shouldn't have done it of course
it's going to be hard bleep but the but
the hardest things in life are the ones
worth doing 100% nothing you know good
ever came easy no no next I'm just going
to just choose to more blindly hey
jackon Claude your podcast is always the
highlight of my day I have a weird one
for you that I hope you choose because I
need your advice well it's your lucky
day I just moved in with my boyfriend
who was absolutely amazing sure I'm
getting he is truly the sweetest and my
family and friends love him just as much
as I do but the past two times he has
gotten drunk he has made some weird
comments to me the first was that he
didn't like kissing me in the morning
because I have morning breath I laugh
this off because everyone has morning
breath and I don't particularly want to
kiss him either agreed but I did change
my behavior and started covering my
mouth even when talking to him in the
morning more recently he brought this
back up saying I think I just figured it
out you just don't brush your teeth for
long enough I was baffled I'm honestly
embarrassed even writing this because
how [__] weird and I have clean teeth
I just went to the dentist have no
cavities and made sure to brush floss I
think he was drunk and truly meant for
this comment to come off as helpful but
it's making me spiral what do I do okay
so I'm like a very breath conscious
person like I me as well been like
before we get out of bed like always
wants to give me a hug yeah and I will
let him hug me from the back yeah like a
spoon situation cuz like I'm just like I
hate breath so I am sympathetic with
this man but I also think like a boy
telling a girl her breath ttings is
different than a girl telling a boy no
and also like morning breath like okay
duh like right no I just want you to
know by the way your breath being
absolute ass in the morning is the most
healthy normal thing like there's
nothing wrong with you good on you for
going to the dentist but there's nothing
wrong with you but to me like and
everybody knows that so who would like
say something to someone it to me it's
giving immaturity I agree we all just
kind of like accept that this is a fact
of life like don't engage with your
partner if you're like not if you can't
handle it handle it then yeah Breeze
past your partner until they brush their
teeth but like to be immature and say
something like that's [__] weird it
is weird and like to try and make you
feel bad about it what what what what
what are you choking be careful be
careful be careful be careful what's
wrong what's wrong what's wrong I just
had a funny
thought CL I just seriously almost you
choked out a it was the worst time to
have a funny thought that' be like
saying to someone that'd be like saying
to someone your duty
smells that would be like saying to
someone your duty smells
duh
yeah and like okay no that would be like
somebody shoving their nose inside your
belly button and be like ew that smells
like yeah that's bodies no they would
like putting their finger in your belly
button and then like taking and say
that's that's C like yeah okay yeah
maybe just like don't put your nose
places doesn't belong no it's like thank
you Captain Obvious yeah duh and like
rude Captain Obvious yeah no this guy's
a dick honestly break
up I literally agree break up with your
boyfriend cuz your breath
smells no I just like honestly I'm in
this era of life where I don't have time
for immaturity you know and neither
should you yeah you want to do one more
yeah let's do one more here's a short
one hi girlies my fiance watches our
ring cameras like a hawk and caught the
neighbor's daughter sneaking out at 3:30
a.m. and returning at 6:00 a.m. twice in
one week I want to talk to her daughter
because I'm worried for her safety but
my fiance says I'm being a anarc help
what should I do well you shouldn't talk
to the daughter like if anything you got
to tell the parents but I need more like
how is she 18 like how or is she 12 you
know probably somewhere in between
probably 16 3:30 to 6:30 is like
actually crazy hours it's not like she's
sneaking out at 11:00 and coming back at
yeah I would see I would case their
joint and see if they have cameras like
maybe they know about this um but yeah I
think you should find a way to tell the
parents like I would want to know and I
would proba I would probably tell
someone like I'm not about being an arc
like if I ever lived in a neighborhood
and I saw like some kids like you know
like having a beer like I wouldn't say
anything but I do think there's like a
line 3:30 like your your teenager is out
at 5: in the morning like that's crazy
times yeah it's not just like there's a
party and she wants to go but her
parents don't let her so she sinks out
at 10 and comes back at 12 you know like
that's classic kids stuff and honestly
that's a right of passage yeah 3:30 to
6:30 there's nothing happening from 3:30
to 6:30 that's good that's good or that
someone should be doing
solo at those hours yeah no I agree I I
hate this is like where you get older
and like you realize like you got an arc
yeah but what she's leaving at 3:30 no
it's crazy times unless she's like
training for the marathon I was going to
say maybe she's going for a run but
still that's too early it's still dark
out it's not safe it's not safe and it's
a young girl like yeah no it's not safe
honestly you're doing her a favor you
have to snitch yeah snitch I agree with
you and your husband's wrong but that's
the least shocking thing we said today
yeah and that's our show dear toaster
are is our weekly advice segment if you
ever want to write in we keep it
Anonymous except for
today dear toasters sorry bleep dear
toasters at gmail.com or head over to
the toast podcast.com and there's a
little submission box there totally
Anonymous thank you guys for a great
show tomorrow we're in studio again
Jackson cler and we'll see you then
thank you so much for listening to the
mill morning where we deliv the stories
need every Friday YouTube watching is on
YouTube please to subscribe video thumbs
up podc
pod beautiful setting and wickedly
talented we are love you
bye